just to ease you back into a drug has
been a little while since we did this
I'm going to show you some questions
that we we know how to do that we've
done before however I wonder if you
remember I wonder how good your memory
is you learn a lot of things so maybe
it's all sort of blurred together um a
couple of months ago we did this lesson
where we did formulas for area squares
rectangles triangles parallelograms the
whole list okay and I have lots of
common carbonate on the board back then
I told you I wanted you to not just know
that something was true but actually
feel that it was true as well and I
think you guys can all do this question
but I want you to get a visual sense for
feeling why it is true not just knowing
that this okay so even though you could
probably do this just right off the bat
I'm actually going to ask you to draw
something with me okay these diagrams
that we're going to draw then what I
hope your mind goes to when you see a
question like this video should pop into
your mind just like when I say the word
dog you almost can't help but visualize
a dog in your mind so there is okay so I
want to do the same thing so here's the
picture I'd like you drop underneath
when you've done five plus surgeons
three I want to visually represent each
of these terms
okay now the five of the three are the
EasyBib I'm just going to literally draw
them as a series of whomps right there's
five Lots over there and there's three
blocks on the end now that that leaves
me the question of how will I draw this
now I've got lots of different choices
at my disposal the tomatoes your way
that I'm going to draw really is to
imagine it like a rectangle like these
are rectangles these are rectangles this
one is five high and it is one wide five
by one which is why it's five right and
this is three by one so when you see 7x
what I imagine is a rectangle that is
seven high and X Y now this is a tricky
thing because I don't know what X is I
don't know where it is so I'm just going
to represent it like this
okay can you see what I've done right so
just like I've got the 5 into 3 which
are 5 high and three high this guy is
seven plus seven five and he's with I
don't know what it is so that's why I've
drawn it kind of like a stretchy thing
right it could be really tiny or it
could be super wide
I don't really know so I'm just gonna
draw that why do you see that this
rectangle is 7x its area is 7x
are you following with me so far now
when you have a look at a diagram like
this like when you first learn algebra
sometimes we've looked at five plus
seven x and we take oh 12 X like because
there's a five and a seven right but
when you look at this diagram hopefully
you can see well these guys can't mix it
all they're kind of talking different
languages right like these are all one
wide the second thing is x1 who knows
how wide that is so that's why when I
collect like terms how would you write
the answer to this this is 8 8 5 plus 3
and then that's 7x just kind of hangs
out on its own right
now what is this look like well clearly
I can just draw this 8 like this there's
my 8 because I just jammed the 5 and the
3 together and then the 7x is still just
hanging out over here
are you with me do you see the way out
now this is a very very simple idea but
it's very powerful okay let me try and
justify that for you let's do another
example
what if I asked you to do this now some
of you know the rules well enough that
you can just give me the answer but
before we do that I want to see if this
tool can help us okay so I'm going to
draw some diagrams in it now some
reasons that I become clear in a second
I'm just gonna leave off these three for
a second if all I had was a V in this
scheme up here how could I represent how
could I draw a B well remember I don't
know what a and B are they just some
numbers so we're going to do is I'm
going to draw a rectangle that is a wine
and beehive that's a B do you see that
like later length times width yes
so this a B but I actually don't want a
B I want three a B okay so I'm just
trying to draw two more so that's three
a bit do you see how it looks now let's
be a you guys know your rules so well
that some of you will say well isn't
that the same as a B but why is it the
same and the answer is well if this is a
wide and big high then this would be B
wide and do you see that like it didn't
actually represent something ever so
slightly different but all I need to do
is take the sky and rotate them around
and then I can slide him underneath just
that makes sense so that's why I clearly
I think just say that's for a B that's
why a b-and-b a are the same because
they represent the same size